All right, I want to start today with the
coronavirus update, I think it's useful to
do this at least once a week last week, people
seem to appreciate it.
And because I look at this stuff every day,
I assume that everybody has all the same information
I have.
And we learned a long time ago when we were
kids, what happens when one assumes and I
don't want to do that.
So let's do the coronavirus update.
I have cautiously good news about cases and
deaths and vaccines, and we're going to discuss
the coronavirus variants and let's get right
into it.
So first of all cases, last week I told you
that after peaking around January 11th, average
daily covid cases were down about 42 percent
as of early last week.
And I said at the beginning of last week,
by the end of last week, meaning Friday, we
would probably be down 50 percent in terms
of daily cases from that peak on January 11th.
And we reached that milestone and we have
now surpassed that milestone.
Covid average daily cases in the United States
are down to one hundred and 10000, still an
insane number, one hundred and ten thousand
cases a day on average.
But that's a 56 percent decline from the peak
on January 11th.
So in basically four weeks, average cases
down 56 percent, which puts us roughly where
we were back on November 10th.
And hopefully that will continue to decline
if cases continue declining at the same rate
that they have been since January 11th, we'd
be down to about forty eight thousand cases
a day by the beginning of March.
It's unlikely that this will be a straight
line decline.
There will be changes, there will be inflection
points.
But this is a very, very good piece of news.
And we will talk about how the variance may
affect these numbers.
Now, what about deaths?
We've previously mentioned at this point,
everybody's probably sick of hearing me say
deaths, lag cases by about three to four weeks.
We would expect that if cases peak on January
11th, deaths would be peaking and starting
to decline around.
Now, is that happening?
Yes, it appears to be happening.
Deaths hit an average peak of about 3400 deaths
per day around the middle of January, more
than a 9/11.
Every single day, the trend line sort of plateaued
and it has started to come down and hopefully
will start to come down more quickly as people
are vaccinated, particularly folks at highest
risk of death.
So that gets us to variance.
And to get to variance, we have to go through
vaccines.
Currently, there are two vaccines approved
for emergency use in the United States.
First was the Fizer vaccine, then the Moderna
vaccine.
Early concerns about supply and delivery have
been replaced by more cautious optimism from
Pfizer and Moderna about their ability to
continue delivering millions of doses per
day.
As many of you know, I was on a sort of on
call list for leftover doses.
At the end of the day, a friend of mine works
at a hospital that has a zero waste commitment
on doses.
And I was able to get my first dose of the
Moderna vaccine about 10 days ago from a left
overdose from canceled appointments.
And the numbers continue to improve.
The U.S. is now giving out an average of one
point four six million doses per day.
Remember, Joe Biden's goal was one million
doses per day for 100 days.
We're at one point for six million doses per
day.
And on Saturday and Sunday, the US actually
did two million doses each day, two million
on Saturday, two million on Sunday.
That is absolutely fantastic.
If we get a third vaccine approved in the
next three weeks, Johnson and Johnson has
submitted their vaccine for approval.
That's a one dose vaccine.
Not inconceivable that the US could get to
2.5 million doses per day.
I mean, I want to be careful, but even three
million doses per day, which would be absolutely
fantastic.
And the one dose nature of the JMJ vaccine
makes the larger the logistics even easier.
Now, cases down, deaths starting to come down,
vaccination starting to go up.
What about the covid variants?
There is a lot of doom and gloom about the
covid variants from the UK, from Brazil and
from South Africa.
Lots of people being very dire about this,
some even saying the vaccines just flat out
don't work against the variants.
So what is the truth?
The truth is really not that bad.
What we know we know the AstraZeneca vaccine,
which is not even approved in the U.S. yet,
really doesn't seem effective against that
South African variant.
That's bad.
They're having problems moving forward.
OK, the Pfizer and Moderna vaccines, which
are approved in the United States.
Seem the way I would characterize it colloquially
without making a mathematical statement is
the Pfizer and Moderna vaccines appear to
be quite effective against the variants, including
the South African variant.
Now, it is true early data suggests you are
less protected against the South African variant
with the Pfizer and Moderna vaccines.
It doesn't mean you are unprotected people.
Immune responses on a on a bell curve, as
many of you know and we've looked at.
And those with a stronger immune response
to the vaccines are probably still protected
against the South African variant and protected
against the British variant.
That's the big one, one seven variant and
the Brazilian variant.
But very importantly, this is not a reason
not to get vaccinated.
It's a reason to get vaccinated as quickly
as possible.
The virus mutates as it spreads.
Every time that the virus goes from one person
to another is an opportunity for a mutation.
The more people you get vaccinated now, fewer
cases, less mutation, fewer variants.
OK, Moderna and Pfizer are studying the variants
they are developing as a sort of insurance
policy, a modified booster shot, but that's
eight, nine, 10 months away based on my current
understanding.
So we don't yet know what the approval process
will be from an FDA standpoint for modified
vaccines.
So what we can do now is there's no point
in waiting.
If you're eligible for a vaccine, get the
vaccine, because if you prevent an infection
or two infections or three infections by being
vaccinated, even if eventually the British,
South African and or Brazilian variants become
the dominant strains, the more people that
have partial protection, the better.
There's no argument for delaying.
There is a debate now about what happens in
three months.
So we've talked about cases are coming down
quickly.
Deaths have leveled and are starting to come
down, but the variants are spreading.
There are some the most pessimistic perspective
who say the variants are going to take over.
The vaccines will not work against them, and
cases will explode again to the level we saw
in December.
I don't think that's the most likely scenario
based on all of the epidemiological data I've
seen and interviews and statements and writing
from immunologists and epidemiologists.
If we keep vaccinating, the January 11th peak
will likely be the final major peak as the
weather starts to improve in the parts of
the country that have winter and more and
more people are vaccinated.
Yes, it is likely true that more and more
of the cases will be the variants, but it
is also true that more and more millions and
tens of millions and hopefully hundreds of
millions of Americans will have sufficient
protection against these variants.
That cases will continue to decline.
And now when we get to then we'll have summer,
et cetera, when we get to the next flu season,
in the fall, hopefully by then there will
be a modified booster, if indeed it's determined
that that's what's necessary.
And my hope is, and I believe it's realistic
but cautious, is that the January 11th peak
was the final peak for this pandemic.
All we can do now is continue to be safe,
continue to vaccinate.
And I've mentioned this before, we should
not undersell the vaccine.
I know people who are saying, listen, I'm
being told even if you get vaccinated, it
may not work against the variants and you
still have to wear a mask.
You still have to social distance.
There are lots of good immunologists and epidemiologists
who are saying, listen, in a month, if the
numbers continue going this way, if you are
fully vaccinated, meaning a week past dose,
too, it's it's a very acceptable level of
risk to have an indoor dinner with six fully
vaccinated people.
Let's be realistic about what this means.
It doesn't mean you go to the grocery store
and you say, I don't have to wear a mask because
I'm vaccinated.
That's going to be the policy for some time
in parts of the country.
I know friends in places like Arizona are
telling me nobody's wearing a mask at the
grocery store, but in much of the country,
that's what's going on.
It'll continue to go on.
But let's be realistic about the game changing
nature of these vaccines.
Will check in about the data again next week.